hey guys what's up this is andrew for
tradingsenses.com
so very quickly i'm a professional
trader and i'm doing right now some
youtube videos
where i want to discuss with you guys
everything that i see at work all the
different tools and techniques that i
use to make money on the markets
so i mostly talk about technical
analysis but i like also to talk
about the option market and synthetic
short interest the delta the gamma
squeeze all the stuff and to explain to
you
what i see so in this video i want to
make a complete update on gamestop
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so for those who have
watched my previous video let's start on
the fourth time frame
you are wondering where is the third
wave
and let's be honest me too
me too but i found something that i want
to show you here
that is actually to me explaining
everything
and you're gonna understand what i mean
very soon
the first thing let me remind you my
scenario and let me quickly
uh remind you what i was saying so this
is a one
this is a two and then i was seeing a
third wave
bam bam bam and we go to 800 all right
so this was my view
last week but remember guys for those
who have watched my videos what
i was saying i was saying that i don't
see any bearish divergence
so i don't see any reason for the price
action suddenly to drop because i don't
have any early signal i see a macd on
the daily timeframe that is positive now
so it's good we were trading above the
173 level
before when i did my last update so i
was telling you guys this is a major
major pivot point let me put it like
this
maybe it's a bit too big
sorry up
all right so this 173 guys
i'm not gonna go through this again but
it had like a lot of reactions in the
past and it's the
to me the uh it's a at the center of my
analysis and we were trading above so i
was telling you alright everything is
good but
remember what i was telling you as well
that i'm missing something that is very
important in third waves
is volumes and you know right now
i need to adapt this is here i was not
sure
but i was okay maybe it's like doing
something like this like small one twos
one two this is a three plus four five
and
inside this one i thought maybe one
two like this
you know and i was trying to see
something like this but once again guys
we cannot we can do one twos one twos
one twos like this
and finally get the third of the third
of the third and then
just have more volume and go up but
let's be honest guys you know i
i felt something was wrong here and
right now
i see the truth i see what is happening
and let me explain to you what i see
so basically when you cannot find an
easy counting
when you see that something is missing
that something is you know doesn't look
good
you need usually to go towards complex
corrections you usually then are in a
correction and you just
you just can't cannot identify exactly
what it is
and here guys i did i went to
the book so i'm going to show you this
very soon but you can find it online
and i'm gonna show you exactly guys what
information i used in this book
about idiot wave theory to come up with
this answer
but this is actually a double three so
what is a double three a double
three or triple three is just a
combination of corrective patterns that
is moving sideways
and here guys as you can see we are
having
my pivot point that i use for like month
one or two months
and we are just you know moving around
this as you can see going sideways
so this put me on the right path telling
me that we are probably doing a complex
correction then
i just needed to identify the patterns
my abc here has always been here it
didn't change
but this whole mess that i could not
you know that i could not find
accounting that is fitting
properly with all the indicators going
together
like volume is actually guys a triangle
and now i see it very clearly
so what we're having is just a double
tree it's the association a combination
of two corrective patterns
so maybe we're gonna have one more we
can do triple trees
but as we should move sideways i'm
expecting the second
corrective pattern the second three to
be
the last one and let me develop my view
a bit more here
so i think we are just doing here a
triangle
after doing this abc we are doing a
triangle all right so this is still my
second wave guys so it doesn't change
anything that the third wave is going to
come
it is just explaining what kind of
correction we're having
and it is giving us hints when it should
be
finished and here let me just check if
this is all making sense if yes i should
find abc's everywhere
so here a b c
a b c very clean
a b c very clean again
and abc guys all right so this is
telling me that
we are indeed in a triangle so what
can we expect now so i don't know if the
d
wave is here or here whatever but what
we expect we can expect now
guys is another abc all right something
like this
so i give you my view for the coming
week i think we are gonna
rebound around 150 we won't be trading
lower than this even 154
i don't think gamestop would be trading
lower than this i think we're gonna
go back to the pivot point get rejected
then
rebound again on the downward sloping
trendline that is acting as support
here on the lower band of my triangle
around 165
then go to the upper band we then gonna
finish the e wave of the triangle
triangles have five waves then this
would bring us
in the 14th of may around so during the
end of the week so i think this week is
gonna be bullish
and then we're gonna have probably so
either
we're doing one more tree all right so
it's possible so kind of a zigzag and
then we go higher
all right this is possible but this is
not my preferred scenario and once again
i use other indicators to tell me this
so if i see any bearish divergence here
it would maybe make me think that this
is what is happening but for now
this is not the case at all we are
around this pivot point
and i think that if we break it on the
upside it's going to hold
and i expect something like this we get
rejected here
we go higher we take this level we go
higher
and we finally go to the upside and do
this
third wave so this is what i think very
quickly guys what i want to show you
as well is that all the information i'm
giving you you know
is not something that i just take from
my mind
you just type elliot wave principle
frost and pressure
pdf in google you take the second link
guys
here you do control f and you type
double
three and the third sorry fifth
information you're gonna find so this is
the idiot wave principle book guys this
is a lot of precious information
not easy to read though and here let me
just read for you guys what i found this
morning once again it took me around two
hours before coming up with this
scenario that i believe in very strongly
so idiot called sideways combinations of
corrective patterns double threes
and triple threes while a single three
is any zigzag flat
we know that zigzag and flat they have
three waves abc
a triangle is an allowable final
component of such combinations in this
context
is called three so basically you can use
a triangle as a three
so it's just you know to show you guys
that this is not coming from me it's
coming from the book
that's why my second three is actually a
triangle a double or triple three
then is a combination of simpler types
of corrections
so it becomes then a complex correction
which is not easy to spot guys that's
why that's why i was traveling
a bit with it including the various
types of zigzags
flat and triangles all right that's
exactly what i told you
the occurrence appears to be the flat
corrections way
of extending sideways action you can see
that this is exactly what is happening
as with double and triple zigzag each
simple corrective pattern is level w
y and z all right we don't care about
that so once again you can see guys here
we are moving sideways
and this whole mess is just a very
complex correction
that i just identified right now
and i'm giving it to you right away so
i hope you guys enjoyed this video i
hope i managed to explain to you how
in trading we adapt how we actually
guess that something is wrong here it
was with the volumes
so you know i would not stay in my
scenario that i know
is not happening i quickly tried to
adapt
to find a solution and come up with a
new
view that is actually just delaying my
original view
that is anyway a one two and a three
coming that is gonna go
you know much much higher and then of
course four
and five so if you enjoyed this video
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i see you
guys